bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo 45 minutes pour faire ensemble le
tour de l'actualité politique - jour
michael
serge dassault conserve son immunité
parlementaire le bureau du sénat a
rejeté mercredi la demande de l'île
levée d'immunité du sénateur dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur des achats
présumé de vote à corbeil essonnes 13
sénateurs s'y sont opposés dont
certainement un socialiste tollé au
sénat le pacte de responsabilité c'était
la promesse de françois hollande aux
entreprises lors de ses voeux du 31
décembre tournant social libéral ou
continuité de sa politique la baisse des
charges annoncées agitée en tout cas les
couloirs du parlement enfin le plus de
l'hebdo ministre ou rien c'est le titre
d'un documentaire diffusé la semaine
prochaine 24 ministres ont livré leur
vision du métier comment fait-on
l'apprentissage du poste et quelles sont
les relations entre ministres ou encore
comment vivaient-ils les arbitrages
budgétaires
à découvrir à la fin de l'émission
évidemment toute cette actualité et on
va la développer avec vous nicole bricq
bonjour bonjour ministre en charge des
relations du commerce extérieur on va
développer ensemble toute l'actualité de
la semaine et je voudrais que l'on
commence par ce début de semaine qui
était marqué par des unes de presse qui
ont fait couler beaucoup d'encre je
commençais par nos pas là une de closer
on en parlera peut-être un petit peu
plus tard mais du magazine américain
newsweek
vous avez peut-être vu c'est une avec
the fall of friends qu'on peut traduire
par l'effondrement de la france
comparaison de la france de françois
hollande à celle de louis xiv en cause
une forme d'état nous nous une forme de
caricature de forme de french bashing
vous qui voyagez à travers le monde vous
le ressentez seconde machine non parce
que partout où je vais dans le monde la
france est ressentie comme une terre
d'innovation et les américains ne
citerons ne peut pas quand je regarde
les chiffres nous sommes le premier pays
en europe à accueillir des investisseurs
américains ça représente 450 mille
emplois 4200 entreprises américaines
implantées sur notre sol donc ça veut
dire que quand même on n'a eu qu'à
passer l'attraction alors c'est vrai que
c'est une forme de caricature de la part
des journalistes de newsweek mais elle
en dit peut-être aussi assez long sur 7
et aminu comme elle l'appelle l'état où
finalement tout est dû aux français
l'état c'est important dans un pays
lui donne quand même des capacités
d'agir mais il faut qu'il soit agile
réactif et rapide c'est le sens qu'a
voulu donner dans son message aux corps
constitués
or le message du président de la
république il ya une suite à cet article
le journaliste parle des élites qui fuit
la france de manque d'entrepreneurs en
france comment vous réagissez nous
n'avons pas assez d'entreprises
c'est vrai je le constate et pas assez
d'entreprises exportatrices mais nous
avons des entrepreneurs qui se battent
au delà de nos frontières et
cette affaire d'exil écoutez moi j'étais
à la commission des finances à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat et à
chaque fois
nous avions quand notamment nous étions
dans l'opposition nous avions ce cette
ritournelle on n'a jamais pu montrer
démontrer que il y avait une fuite vers
l'étranger jamais ça n'a pu être
démontré avec des chiffres sérieux alors
on arrête alors autre article justement
cette semaine celui du findel charles
times qui consacrait mardi donc en une
un article sur la prise d'otage des deux
dirigeants est de goodyear le retour du
boss nappe d'in the sith qui a infesté
le pays pendant la crise financière de
2009 une action du syndicat radicale la
cgt qui traduit la dégradation des
relations entre les salariés et la
direction est ce que vous trouvez que
cette analyse du financial times et
juste l'image n'est pas bonne c'est
clair mais elle n'est pas bonne pour la
france et pour les français
je pense que
le gouvernement très tôt a condamné
cette prise d'otages et j'ai vu qu'ils
compris le leader de la cgt à monsieur
le pan avait pris ses distances avec ces
méthodes est bon
arnaud montebourg le mini du
redressement productif a appelé à la
raison et au retour on a là une
personnalité syndicale forte mais qui
est dans le mauvais chemin et je crois
que effectivement ce n'est pas bon pour
l'image de la france parce qu'elles ne
correspondent pas à la réalité il faut
mettre en avant que nous avons réalisés
sous l'égide de michel sapin deux
accords fondamentaux à la fois sur la
flexibilité du travail et en même temps
l'accord sur la formation
professionnelle c'est ça que je mets en
avant le dialogue social ça peut exister
en france d'après m les syndicats en
france ou pas non je crois que le
syndicalisme mériterait d'être plus fort
il n'y a pas assez de syndiqués on le
sait on a des syndicats et par pillés et
je crois que la réforme que va présenter
michel sapin sur la représentativité va
aider finalement à ce que les syndicats
soient plus forts mais est-ce qu'il faut
pas se tourner vers un syndicalisme à
l'anglo-saxonne là on a une tradition en
france on est français et donc on va pas
copier les autres on a une histoire
aussi il faut jamais gommer l'histoire
des peuples qui fait que nous avons ce
syndicalisme là bon il faut le prendre
en compte il faut appuyer les efforts
que font les dirigeants syndicaux pour
justement participé aux négociations et
apporter ce qu'ils ont à apporter je
crois que la démocratie sociale fait
partie de la démocratie tout court
nicole bricq autres une de presse qui
d'une certaine façon touche à l'image de
la france c'est le magazine people
closer qui elle a une et sur cette page
annonce une liaison présumée autres le
président est une actrice julie gayet le
président s'est exprimé à titre
personnel il déplore cette atteinte à la
vie privée se réserve le droit d'action
judiciaire au delà tout ça ce que c'est
pas la fonction du président qui est
désacralisée le président s'est exprimé
moi je n'ai pas de commentaires à faire
c'est la vie privée ça ne me regarde pas
le président est il un citoyen comme un
autre et ce qu'on peut non bien sûr que
non bien sûr que non il reçoit l'onction
populaire
au travers du suffrage universel direct
tellement c'est ce que ce qu'est ce que
l'on demande au président dans la crise
actuelle on lui demande de tout faire
pour que la france s'en sorte et que
pour les français et plus d'emplois et
de bons emplois s'est fait d'oser ça qui
m'intéresse c'est que c'est quand même
une très mauvaise nouvelle pour le
président de la république je sais pas
de commentaire votre commentaire est ce
qui devrait porter plainte la question
c'est à lui de saïx s'est exprimée moi
je n'ai rien à ajouter à ce qu'il a dit
alors si vous le voulez bien d'en
revenir à l'actualité présidentielle
officielle cette fois lundi et françois
hollande faisait ses voeux aux corps
constitués et il s'est interrogé sur les
lourdeurs de l'état ecoutez-le
l'état lui-même est jugé trop lourd trop
lent
trop cher
et il est vrai que son organisation
apparaît de plus en plus mystérieuses
avec eux ces agences ces opérateurs ces
autorités
avec la question qui est posée mais où
se prend donc la décision
il est également exact que
l'enchevêtrement des compétences
avec les collectivités locales paraît de
plus en plus à déchiffrable aussi nous
devrons pas nous devons répondre aux
questions que nos concitoyens se pose
qui fait quoi dans notre pays qui est
responsable de quoi et qui paye en
dernier ressort et convenons que les
réponses ne sont pas toujours apporté de
façon claire alors nicole bricq l'état
est il trop lent trop lourd trop cher
comme le dit le président on a besoin
d'un état agile réactif et rapide
et je crois que le président vise juste
on peut le faire au travers justement
des mesures de simplification qu'il a
demandé très tôt ce choc de
simplification et auquel on s'emploie et
on peut le faire aussi par rapport à sa
productivité à sa compétitivité mais un
état c'est important moi je le constate
parce que
dans les relations économiques
extérieures
c'est vrai que nous sommes vus aussi
comme un pays avec lequel on peut parler
d'autorité a autorité et que moi ça me
permet de passer au delà du l'ère
précédente qui était quand même très
composé d'officine de ministres qui
n'était pas qualifié pour
pour parler et c'est vrai qu'ils avaient
beaucoup il y avait pas écouté il y
avait beaucoup d'officines moi je sais
que monsieur oubliant guéant avait une
chasse gardée était ministre de
l'intérieur
il était à l'elysée il n'est pas
diplomate
il est pas économique mais il avait des
chasses gardées dans certains pays donc
je trouve que c'était pas forcément la
bonne méthode et on a besoin d'un
dialogue d'état à état mais en même
temps l'état a des faiblesses et il doit
les corriger quand on entend trop lourd
on dit alléger est ce que ça veut dire
qu'il faut alléger aussi du côté des
fonctionnaires attendent et
on voudrait on a arrêté la rgpp le
premier ministre un chantier qui saluait
la modernisation de l'action publique et
qui procède
rationnellement on évalue et on agit
donc en fonction de l'évaluation on agit
pour cette rendre justement cette étape
les outrances user à non certainement
pas attendez moi ont encore cette année
on est on en a besoin quand je vois
certains postes extérieurs dont je suis
responsable
qui sont sous ma tutelle dans certains
pays je me dis mais il faut faire mieux
avec ce que l'on a mais c'est une force
mais l'état trop lent trop cher c'est
aussi un discours du précédent
gouvernement du précédent président de
droite mais le travail du président de
la république c'est d'envoyer des
messages pour que tout le monde s'y met
et l'état à sa part moi je le vois dans
mon action il faut être actif je les dis
ça veut dire qu'il faut se redéployer
rapidement là où il ya la croissance là
où il y a des marchés pour les
entreprises françaises c'est ce que nous
faisons quand nous ouvrons un poste au
kenya quand nous allons sur des marchés
qui ne sont pas habituelles quand nous
ouvrons un poste en birmanie quand
l'opérateur commercial ubifrance se
déploie aussi dans la rapidité en
enlevant
dans des pays plus matures pour aller
vers des pays émergents auprès émergents
ça c'est un n'est pas souple rapide et
réactif et rapide réactif ça passe aussi
peut-être par décret des ordonnances en
tout cas c'est ce que veut le président
de la république peut-être au détriment
du pont du brault explications camilia
quand on possède
place aux ordonnances pour accélérer le
tempo une manière pour le gouvernement
de légiférer sans passer par le
processus parlementaire la nouvelle ne
réjouit personne au sénat mais la
majorité se montrent compréhensives je
pense qu'il ya un contexte d'urgence
parce que les attentes de nos
concitoyens sur un certain nombre de
mesures notamment sur la fiscalité
il y à une nécessité d'aller vite
probablement sur le lampe orage est un
bon compromis tout dépend du sujet un
compromis imposé aussi par les cinq
semaines de pause parlementaire prévue
pour les élections municipales une
justification peu crédible pour
l'opposition en nous qui est in chaque
jour un petit peu plus et cette
déclaration on n'est qu'une preuve
supplémentaire mais c'est un problème
qui est interne à la majorité
présidentielle
leur incapacité effectivement à
s'entendre avec la partie la plus à
gauche de la majorité présidentielle et
je trouve que c'est dommage que ce soit
la démocratie française qui en fasse les
frais pour un gouvernement qui a
beaucoup de choses à faire sur la
réforme on est presque à la moitié du
rythme du président précédent il
explique par
manifestement une grande inexpérience
dans la pratique du pouvoir et
les illusions six pompes les
parlementaires n'auront pourtant pas le
temps de souffler d'ici aux élections
municipales le calendrier est bien
chargé à l'ordre du jour du sénat la
liberté des mers concernant les rythmes
scolaires ou encore le vote par internet
aux élections européennes pour les
français à l'étranger mais priorité à
certains projets de loi comme le cumul
des mandats la formation professionnelle
et l'accès au logement le gouvernement
espère faire passer neuf textes avant
les prochaines élections un marathon
législatif ambitieux alors autant que
ministre on imagine que passer par des
ordonnances à vous facilite un petit peu
la vie mais vous qui avez été une
parlementaire à 6 du est ce que vous
trouvez ça normal vous avez entendu
chantal jouanno owni piétine
là quand même je voudrais pas être
méchante mais qui a limité le temps de
parole des parlementaires à l'assemblée
nationale c'est quand même une majorité
de droite bon pourrait reprendre le moi
j'avais beaucoup rouspéter quand madame
kosciusko morizet avait voulu sur et
petits cement réformer le code minier
sans passer par la loi mais par
ordonnance en même que leur donnant soit
habilité
que je veux dire c'est un outil moi j'ai
toujours reconnu vous pouvez reprendre
mes déclarations j'ai toujours reconnu
que c'était un outil au service de
l'exécutif c'est la cinquième république
c'est la constitution mais je pense que
les parlementaires ont les moyens
d'intervenir par l'habilitation
justement il nous est arrivé quand
j'étais parlementaire au sénat
d'encadrer des ordonnances en disant ce
que le parlement souhaitait et c'est
vrai que dans la majorité on peut aussi
travailler avec en confiance avec
l'objectif de parlements des exécutifs
législatifs mais c'est vrai qu'on est
dans une période exceptionnelle
si l'année 2014 est une année charnière
et regardez par exemple la formation
professionnelle c'est un accord très
important
qui a été négocié et ce qui est
important c'est que ça ils vont
relativement vite même très vite donc il
faut de ce texte non mais il faut que ce
texte soit voté avant la fin du mois de
février pour pouvoir après se décliner
regarder le texte sur l'accord
interprofessionnel sur la flexisécurité
le temps après que ça pénètre dans les
entreprises parce que derrière cet
accord et cette loi doit être décliné
dans les entreprises justement gosses
yassa claude bartolone le président de
l'assemblée a dit restreindre d'accord
mais il faut surtout en finir avec les
loi bavarde est-ce que c'est pas la
halle du problème c'est ce que vous
disiez à l'instant
c'est sur un coup on a parlé on a bon
mais ça aussi c'est la responsabilité
des parlementaires et de l'opposition
notamment regarder
franchement le mariage pour tous
qui a occupé l'espace parlementaires
parce que l'opposition
faisait du retardement donc il faut
aussi être responsable qu'est ce qui est
important qu est ce qui l'est moins
lorsque pour éviter des deux côtés
l'exécutif et du parlementaire nicole
bricq la semaine politique a été marquée
par la sphère dieudonné le gouvernement
s'en est saisie jusqu'au président de la
république s'était marty
on l'a dit le cas dieudonné à alimenter
toute la semaine politique déclarations
du ministre de l'intérieur envoie la
circulaire aux préfets demande de
fermeté du gouvernement et mardi les
premières interdictions du spectacle
sont tombés puis les recours en justice
finalement le conseil d'état a tranché
dieudonné n'a pas pu se produire à
nantes un sujet de thomas souilhe et
14h30 tribunal administratif de nantes
après quatre heures d'attentes la fin du
suspense à la halle des messieurs j'ai
le très grand plaisir de vous annoncer
que par décision rendue aujourd'hui par
dessus le président du tribunal
administratif de nantes le spectacle de
dieudonné va se tenir ce soir c'est donc
un échec pour le préfet c'est un échec
pour le ministre qui a voulu interdire
l'artiste dans ce qu'il a appelé ses
meetings qui ne sont jamais que des
spectacles
aujourd'hui c'est la consécration de la
liberté d'expression manuel valls a
perdu sa première bataille juridique
face à dieudonné malgré la circulaire
envoyée aux préfets
le spectacle aura lieu d'urgence le
ministre de l'intérieur saisit le
conseil d'état côté politique les
réactions se multiplient
l'opposition remet en cause la gestion
du dossier par le ministre mais c'est
une erreur grave qui met en cause la
crédibilité de l'état l'autorité de
l'état et jeux en tant que citoyen je
suis
choquée parce que le méchant est en
train de gagner et que le gouvernement
s'est trompé donc c'est quand même faire
un peu cher payé cet après midi en
vérité monsieur valls est le carburant
de dieudonné c'est absurde enfin moi je
condamne les paroles racistes
antisémites comme de tout le monde mais
pourquoi en avoir fait ainsi un objectif
politique c'est une instrumentalisation
malheureuse et qui est contre-productive
17h30 manuel valls contre attaque en
déplacement en bretagne
le ministre de l'intérieur répond aux
accusations sans attendre la décision du
conseil d'état il assume ses décisions
face à cette créativité de l'aele
fallait-il ne rien faire
certainement pas d'ores et déjà nous
avons gagné le combat politique de la
mobilisation et du sursaut 19 heures
coup de théâtre le conseil d'état rend
sa décision deux heures avant le début
du spectacle à nantes la représentation
est annulé mais désormais les tribunaux
administratifs dont ils suivre la
décision du conseil d'état en clair
dieudonné pourra-t-il jouer dans
d'autres villes le feuilleton ne fait
que commencer
nicole bricq la méthode valser est elle
la bonne
on ne s'amuse pas avec l'antisémitisme
et s'il faut s'étonner c'est que l'on
n'ait pas agi plus tôt parce que il ya
des moments où il faut dire stop et je
considère que le ministre de l'intérieur
est garant de l'ordre public et garant
du respect des lois peut-être plus que
d'autres ministres et il a occupé la
fonction est ce qu'il n'a pas pris trop
de risques
mais là il fallait agir il a agi en
conformité avec la loi et maintenant il
y à une jurisprudence
vous pensez que cette décision de
l'arrêt du conseil d'état en tout cas il
ya un acte de jurisprudence qui est
quand même la yarra dans la hiérarchie
des normes
administratives
maintenant c'est un feuilleton quotidien
les joueurs et leurs enseignants contre
je pense que non et surtout on a adoubé
la circulaire de manuel valls enfin la
circulaire du gouvernement
elle donne un cadre aux autorités
locales pour agir toi les préfets ou les
maires il faut aussi que tout le monde
prenne ses responsabilités dans la
sphère alors justement est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas aussi que la
justice prenne ses responsabilités
dieudonné a été condamné à plusieurs
reprises il organiser son insolvabilité
oui mais ça moi je connais pas le détail
de tout ça ça m'intéresse modérément je
dois dire un mois ce qui ce que je
retiens c'est que je retiens que
d'une certaine manière et d'une manière
forte en tout cas on a dit stop
si sémitisme qui est diffusée de manière
ignoble ignoble n'est pas que ça
devienne le symbole que ça revient comme
un boomerang cette affaire dieudonné
j'ai entendu qu'il avait hier soir dit à
ses partisans parce que c'est quand même
ça les partisans ceux qui étaient
rassemblés bon de rentrer chez eux bon
voilà donc qui a fait un appel au calme
alors lors de séjours est passé sur un
autre sujet françois hollande a annoncé
un pacte de responsabilité aux
entreprises une forme de donnant donnant
qui détaillerait la semaine prochaine
lors de sa conférence de presse reste
que cette annonce est bien en a surpris
plus d'un à l'assemblée nationale
reportage françois goulet
première séance de questions au
gouvernement depuis les voeux de
françois hollande et sa promesse
d'alléger les charges des entreprises
l'opposition ne crois pas
le président de la république à bully
nous faire croire un changement de cap
avec son pacte de responsabilité
nous sommes le premier gouvernement
depuis très longtemps qui justement
diminuer les charges et la fiscalité sur
les entreprises de façon significative
dans le budget pour 2014 ces 10
milliards d'allègements net de charges
sur les entreprises dans le cas de la
montée en puissance de crédit
compétitivité emploi donc lorsque vous
dites que les charges qui pèsent sur les
entreprises augmentent c'est totalement
faux nous allons poursuivre cette
stratégie le gouvernement tient bon
voilà une réforme innovantes que la
droite elle-même n'a pas eu le cran
d'appliquer et l'objectif est toujours
le même la lutte contre le chômage il
n'y a pas de tournant dans la politique
qui est menée par le président de la
république et le gouvernement depuis 18
mois nous menons depuis le premier jour
la même politique pour le redressement
du pays avec une obsession permanente
c'est l'obsession de l'emploi l'emploi
est toujours l'emploi réduire les
charges chiche rétorque l'ump un peu
pris au dépourvu par les voeux
présidentiels si le socialisme français
évolue vers le marché tant mieux tant
mieux qu'on n'ait plus de débats
philosophiques sur le coût du travail en
france sur la compétitivité
déconcerté la droite certes mais au
risque de fâcher les communistes et le
président de la république tombe dans
cette marmite qui consiste à dire qu'il
y ait un seul ingrédient c'est celui des
charges pour les entreprises mais il
oublie quand même quelque chose
d'essentiel c'est le coût du capital
dans une semaine françois hollande a
promis de détailler le fameux pacte lors
d'une conférence de presse nicole bricq
vous avez déclaré qu'il n'y a pas de
changement de cap pas de tournant de la
part du président et pourtant si on
écoute bien ici la gauche de la gauche
en tout cas les communistes on est très
très loin du candidat hollande 2012
mon ennemi c'est la finance
mais je souris parce que franchement à
regarder les images de l'opposition et
encore vous n'avez pas montré la
conférence de presse de celui qui se
révéla m le chef potentiel de
l'opposition quand je crois qu'elle
s'est complètement emberlificoté dans
son histoire de tournant qui n'avait pas
tourné tout
donc ça me fait sourire maintenant plus
sérieusement le président de la
république a confirmé ce qui était
engagé depuis 2012 notamment depuis
l'automne 2012 il ya eu le rapport
gallois toujours la même méthode on
évalue et on agit est tout de suite dans
la foulée il y a eu le pacte de
compétitivité le 6 novembre où chacun et
notamment en ce qui concerne les
ministres économique nous avons reçu
notre notre pack et d'engagement à
prendre et j'ai reçu le mien temple sur
l'attractivité que sur la compétitivité
à l'export donc on est dans la ligne de
ce qui a été engagé tout en 2012 et qui
s'applique alors en 2013 on a eu une
année terrible hein mais il fallait que
toutes ces mesures entrent en
application
2014 au moment où s'amorce une reprise
notamment en europe et dans la zone euro
il faut être capable de monter dans le
train et il faut monter en tête j'ai
bien retenu ce qu'a dit le président de
la république dans ses voeux aux corps
constitués dans la mondialisation la
france doit toujours être en tête
l'opposition a dit chiche donc vous leur
répondez tout cela se fera bien en 2014
ah oui il ya des engagements qui ont été
pris à la fin de l'année dernière auprès
des entreprises sur les assises de la
fiscalité il y a aussi
des allègements de charges qui ont été
engagées au travers du cic eu un il va
produire ses effets en 2014 et en même
temps il y as certainement à regarder
des politiques parce que tout ça se fait
sur sur le fond important du
désendettement quand on arrive à 95% du
de dette ça veut dire que c'est un
handicap pour la croissance et il faut
réduire nos déficits
donc il faut le faire dans ce cadre là
et quand on vous accuse de mener la
politique du medef
moi je ne reçois pas je ne reçois pas
je ne reçois pas cet argument pas du
tout je m'y oppose complètement parce
que j'emmène dans mes voyages des
entrepreneurs chaque fois que je me
déplace j'ai une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs plus tous ceux que je
rencontre qui sont eux sur le terrain
extérieur et je vois des entrepreneurs
qui se battent tous les jours et je vois
aussi que nous avons des marges pour nos
entreprises beaucoup trop faible donc
ils ne peuvent pas investir ils ne
peuvent pas se déployer et il faut
absolument alors maintenant le pacte de
responsabilité c'est qu'est ce que vous
faites avec ce que l'état fait l'état a
pris sa part il a mis en branle des
mesures fortes et importantes
il a lui même beaucoup déployé des
contrats des emplois aidés maintenant
qu'est-ce que les entreprises font
comment transforme-t-elle ces mesures en
emplois et en investissement parce que
moi je sais que si une entreprise
n'investissent pas elles se privent
d'aller sur les marchés extérieurs car
elle n'innove pas l'aval du sénat nicole
bricq et de mercredi avec le cac
dassault qui a semé le trouble
13 voix contre 12 et une abstention le
vote a été serré pourtant le bureau du
sénat a rejeté pour la deuxième fois la
demande de levée d'immunité de serge
dassault dans une enquête faite dans le
cadre d'une hache a présumé de vote à
corbeil essonnes les explications de
camilia campusano elf a reculé tout le
sénat ne parle aujourd'hui que de cela
la non levée de l'immunité parlementaire
de serge dassault alors que tous les
élus de gauche s'interroge en vain pour
savoir qui sont les deux voix manquantes
dans leur camp tous se range derrière la
proposition de jean pierre bel et accuse
le coup cette défection à gauche que je
déplore qu'ils aient vraiment
cheveux en dessous de tout mais je pense
que jean pierre bel a raison de proposer
aujourd'hui que sur cette question et
bien chacun assume ses responsabilités
quand on est élu au bureau on est un élu
et on assume ses prises de position les
écologistes veulent même aller plus loin
à l'image de leurs représentants au
bureau du sénat qui affirme avoir voté
en faveur de la levée d'immunité hier le
bureau doit avoir des règles qui est la
même et qui doit pas dépendre
effectivement de l'appartenance
politique et la règle c'est noël
immunité parlementaire pour permet pour
garantir l'expression la libre
expression des parlementaires oui
mesdames unités parlementaire doit pas
exister pour des délits de droit commun
un vote public une règle systématique
pas question pour la droite qui défend
le secret du vote car le président du
sénat ou encore les présidents des
commissions sont eux aussi élus à
bulletin secret en clair c'est toutes
les règles rien qu'il faudrait changer
il est exact qu'à l'unanimité du bureau
nous avons retenu cette procédure parce
que le vote personnel est un principe et
nous avons considéré que c'était un vote
de conscience et non un vote de
discipline politicienne j'appelle donc à
la conscience la majorité du bureau du
sénat c'est sa conscience qu'elle doit
examiner et rien d'autre jean pierre bel
veut faire modifier un règlement à la
prochaine réunion du bureau les juges
pourront eux demander une troisième fois
la levée d'immunité du sénateur de
l'essonne si la règle a changé les
prochains votes des 26 représentant au
bureau ouvrons être dévoilés alors vous
qui avez été sénatrice 1 pendant assez
longtemps est ce que vous estimez que
l'image du sénat est entachée j'trouve
ça fait pas dans le tableau c'est pas
terrible quand même il faut bien le dire
ça tombe ça tombe mal pour le sénat qui
a du mal à trouver sa place c'est
compliqué donc c'est compliqué bon
le problème de ne pas avoir de majorité
ferme est un handicap surtout dans la
période mais moi ce que je voudrais
c'est que sans faire de commentaire je
crois que jean pierre béal a raison il
faut revenir à l'essentiel peut-être
dans le règlement intérieur
peut-être mais c'est pas ça l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est de revenir à la source
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'immunité parlementaire ce n'est
certainement pas avoir un traitement
privilégié mais c'est aussi garantir
l'indépendance du parlementaire et je
crois qu'il faut pas j'ai entendu qu'on
pourrait supprimer l'indemnité est quand
même constitue l'un des mythes et la la
l'immunité parlementaire qui est quand
même constitutionnel je pense qu'il faut
raison garder et il faut se poser la
question qu'est ce que l'immunité
parlementaire dans le monde contemporain
donc si regardez cette immunité
parlementaire moi je suis à me demander
mon avis mais ça je respecte
complètement
le parlement c'est à 2 de voir ce qu'il
faut faire sénateurs comme du reste
député il ne faut pas que les gens aient
le sentiment que c'est une protection
que eux dont eux ne disposent pas ça je
comprends très bien mais en même temps
il faut voir que le parlementaire doit
quelque part
être aussi protégé dans son indépendance
d'esprit il ne peut pas être sous la
suspicion permanente
donc c'est pas facile mais je crois
qu'il faut vraiment revenir qu'est ce
que cette immunité parlementaire et
s'interroger sur sa compo
contemporanéité mais justement ce vote a
fait monter justement une montée
d'antiparlementarisme
hier vous la comprenez et puis je crois
qu aussi que quand on fait le parti du
bureau d'une assemblée il faut savoir
qu'on peut être confronté à ce type de
problème est peut-être que effectivement
là c'est là où la proposition du
président bayle de revoir le règlement
intérieur du sénat est utile parce que
c'est vrai que c'est une responsabilité
en un mot ça vous surprend sac montée de
l'antiparlementarisme même partie par
militer c'est pas ils mentent et parce
que c'est pas une montée parce que quand
vous aviez dans le temps il y avait un
grand que un grand hebdo qui faisait
tous les ans un classement
des élus et les parlementaires étaient
toujours les plus mal côté par l'opinion
et les derniers s'étaient les sénateurs
le premier dans l'opinion c'était l'été
les maires qui était toujours en tête
parce qu'il ya là tout de la proximité
donc je pense que ce n'est pas nouveau
il ya toujours eu ce fonds est
effectivement ça vient mal mais je pense
que il faut aussi penser que beaucoup de
gens se battent pour avoir des
parlements libre et que ça fait partie
quand même de l'histoire de france
d'avoir un parlement fort et qu'ils
soient là pour voter les lois mais aussi
pour en faire alors mercredi toujours au
sénat les sénateurs ont adopté à
l'unanimité la loi anti amazon elle
défend les librairies traditionnelles
face aux géants de la vente sur internet
les libraires s'en félicitent les
détails avec nathalie guille war
ici dans cette librairie indépendante du
14e arrondissement de paris on dénonce
la concurrence déloyale qui génère des
entreprises comme amazon jusqu'ici ces
opérateurs en ligne cumuler la gratuité
des frais de ports du livre avec la
remise autorisé de 5% ça constitue un
désavantage pour les librairies de
proximité puisque
implicitement
s'amène au fait que la vente sur
internet est qualifié pour faire des
remises déguisé sous forme de gratuité
des frais de livraison au client final
pour remédier à cette situation une
noire est prévue baptisé anti amazon
elle vise à favoriser les librairies en
empêchant les opérateurs en ligne de
vendre des ouvrages à des prix
inférieurs à ceux imprimés sur les
couvertures pour le syndicat de la
librairie française cette loi serait un
bol d'air pour les librairies c'est un
pas extrêmement important c'est une
manière en consolidant en développant ce
chiffre d'affaires que les libraires
font sur internet de compenser l'érosion
des pentes en magasin ou l'érosion des
ventes aux bibliothèques et aux écoles
pour cette sénatrice cette loi était
donc indispensable pour contrer ces
opérateurs en ligne qui profitaient de
ces avantages il utilise à outrance et
on utilise en outre ans ils
affaiblissent les libraires qui ont des
charges de personnel qui sont 17 fois
plus élevé que les charges de personnel
de ces plates formes en ligne et qui
rendent un service complètement
inestimable ce texte voté mercredi soir
à l'unanimité par les sénateurs doit
désormais repartir à l'assemblée pour
une seconde lecture avant son adoption
définitive
alors que cette loi va mettre fin au
dumping du géant amazon du géant ne rend
elle ne mettra pas fin mais c'est un
très bon signal parce que une librairie
qui ferme une librairie qui meurt c'est
une part de nous mêmes qui s'en va et
moi je note que ce débat a été
extrêmement utiles ma collègue aurélie
filippetti a tout de suite débloquer des
fonds pour soutenir les libraires on en
a besoin enfin en tout cas moi j'en
souffre
c'est un géant américain
il fait partie de ce que je qualifie le
ghana google appelle netflix
et amazon bon c'est un des enjeux du
reste du débat avec les etats-unis
europe et
bien il il appliquera la loi et puis ce
qu'il faut aussi c'est que tout ce petit
monde là quand ils sont implantés enfin
en france paye la fiscalité qu'ils
doivent alors on peut justement ce jeudi
vous est sur tous les fronts
et en attendant les chiffres du commerce
extérieur mieux vous étiez au sénat pour
une discussion sur le projet d'accord de
libre échange entre la france et les
états unis on en parle est justement
avec le cas amazon alors sujets qui
pourraient peut-être paraître abstrait
pour tout le monde pourtant qui concerne
toutes nos entreprises alors où est ce
qu'on dormait aujourd'hui concrètement
qu'est ce que ça pourrait apporter à nos
entreprises oursons les discussions avec
les états unis mais les états unis sont
bien reparti dans la crise sont tus 3%
quand même de croissance c'est assez
remarquable et en même temps sont une
terre d'innovation et donc nous avons
intérêt à aller avec nos entreprises
versaient terre d'innovation c'est pour
ça qu'on négocie aussi au niveau de
l'union européenne car c'est une
politique commune au même titre que la
politique agricole elle est européenne
la politique commerciale avec les pays
tiers donc on est en négociations avec
le japon qui est aussi une terre
d'innovation est par ailleurs un très
bon investisseur en france et on a
négocié avec la corée aussi on a un
accord qui s'applique et on arrive à la
fin de course pour un accord avec le
canada qui est aussi une terre
d'innovation donc on ya un intérêt
objectif à
partir du moment où on est traité comme
des partenaires parce que l'union
européenne c'est la première puissance
commerciale du monde et tout le monde
veut faire un accord de libre échange
avec l'union européenne c'est que il
considère qu'on est attractif donc il
faut que nos entreprises puissent aller
vers ces marchés plus facilement et que
l'accès au marché soit plus facile et
les états unis contrairement à la
réputation de libre-échange y sont très
protectionniste donc tout l'enjeu est là
d'ouvrir les marchés américains l'impact
aussi sur sur les chiffres oui vous les
avez révélé cette semaine les chiffres
du déficit extérieur 65 milliards
d'euros cela va un peu mieux mais cela
reste tout de même le plus important
déficit d'europe alors votre objectif
c'était d'arriver à l'équilibré à la fin
du quinquennat est ce que ça vous paraît
encore wii est l'objectif que auquel je
m'étais engagé et qui était celui du
gouvernement c'est de revenir à
l'équilibré de la balance commerciale
énergie ça c'est très important
donc nous sommes déjà arrivés dans cet
objectif affirmé à ce que nous soyons à
peu près à 10 milliards de déficit si
j'enlève l'énergie mais
le plus dur reste à faire c'est à dire
vraiment diminué globalement notre notre
déficit qui est quand même effrayante
donc on sait qu'on a des causes
structurelles pas assez d'entreprises
pas assez d'entreprises exportatrices
pas assez d'innovations même si on
espère d'innovation voilà et donc il
faut que qu'on accélère et c'est le sens
aussi du pacte de responsabilité c'est
l'accélération parce que 2014 et bien
c'est normalement une année de reprise
en europe je dis que c'est une priorité
pour moi l'europe parce qu'on y perd des
parts de marché qui est des parts de
marché qui nous coûtent cher à haute
valeur ajoutée donc il faut profiter de
cette reprise et être en phase non
seulement mondialement mais aussi dans
nos marchés de proximité européen et
quand on regarde les chiffres du mois de
novembre qui ne sont pas bons c'est vrai
que on voit que par exemple automobile
se comporte un peu mieux même si elle
est déficitaire elle se comporte un peu
mieux parce que nos voisins immédiats
qui n'achetaient plus du tout automobile
reprennent un petit peu du poil de la
bête et peuvent acheter des
ministres a exactement alors nicole
bricq vous êtes ministre c'est un poste
convoité qui fait rêver comment les
anciens ministres ont tiré tu leur as et
au gouvernement c'est le plus de l'hebdo
on en a parlé
ministre ou rien c'est le titre d'un
documentaire diffusé la semaine
prochaine jean michel djian est allé à
la rencontre d'anciens ministres de
gauche à droite tous racontent leur
quotidien les joies les désillusions une
désacralisation orchestrée par les
anciens ministres eux mêmes simon
barbarie il faut quand même pas oublier
que ministre a quelque chose à voir avec
minus on est tourné vers le petit chose
c'est un boulot chien on est renvoyé du
jour au lendemain comme une bonne qu'à
voler l'argenterie amélie fait deux
trois choses qu'elle reste wali à gauche
à droite au centre ils ont tous
participé à l'histoire de la vème
république
plus d'une vingtaine d'hommes et de
femmes actuels ou anciens ministres sont
dans ce documentaire ministre ou rien de
jean michel djian construit en entretien
croisé c'est un sentiment d'impuissance
qui prédomine chez des intervenants une
fois passée la joie d'une nomination
pour moi l'état c'était quelque chose
qui fonctionnait bien qu'ils étaient un
outil bien préparé pour les missions
étaient les siennes et arrivant
ministère du logement je découvre qu'on
sait pas vraiment combien il ya de
demandes de logements en france où elles
sont je découvre un état qui est assez
impuissant à agir le pouvoir c'est bien
ça dont il est question dans ce
documentaire à l'aide d'imagés
d'archivés de souvenirs de confidences
personnelles tous l'affirment le pouvoir
est à l'elysée alors pourquoi certains
s'obstinent à vouloir à tout prix
retourner au gouvernement
la frustration un moteur de l'ambition
pour beaucoup de gens c'est très rare
qui se termine bien ou sans amertume ou
s'en est très rare dans le sentiment
d'avoir accompli la page sera toujours
trop tôt dans des conditions
controversées c'est aussi une source de
frustration sur sa beaucoup de gens qui
sont dans le métier politique veulent
revenir voyez corriger des ministre
présenté ici comme des fusibles de la
vème république une désacralisation en
règle de la fonction ministérielle
effectué par les intéressés eux-mêmes
leur humilité et peut-être la meilleure
nouvelle pour nos institutions la classe
politique il faut bien de temps en
traquer les peurs et donc les
remaniements ministériels
même s'il ne servait qu'à faire peur aux
hommes politiques
il serait finalement utile
alors qu'est-ce que vous inspirent ces
mots ministre minus boulot de chien
sentiment d'impuissance
je pense que quand on est appelé à cette
fonction c'est un honneur d'abord parce
que vous représentez la france surtout
quand vous êtes appelés à franchir les
frontières de l'hexagone
moi je sais que lorsque je suis allé
pour la première fois à un conseil
européen
où je dois dire que mes prédécesseurs
n'était pas très
très actif
le silence qui a suivi ma première
déclaration a été un motif vraiment de
me rendre compte que la voix de la
france ça comptait et donc c'est ça a
été vraiment un motif de satisfaction si
vous voulez tout savoir mais surtout
c'est un service on est là en service et
puis vous savez je suis pas d'accord
avec l'idée que c'est tout ou rien on
que c'est un métier de chien suite
astreignant mais il y en a plein de
métiers guison astreignant m franchement
celui qui va tous les matins à prendre
sans rer qui se lève à 5h30 le erreur
n'arrive pas tout le temps bas celui là
il a plus de mérite que nous mais je
crois que ça peut pas être tout ou rien
il ya plein de gens qui font plein de
choses du reste le conte témoigner ils
font plein de choses après et puis vous
savez il ya une bonne méthode ya une
bonne méthode il faut acheter son pain
tous les jours ou pour deux jours parce
que maintenant le garde bien et puis il
faut faire ses courses il faut savoir
prendre le rer ou le métro est comme ça
je peux vous dire que vous continuez
dans la vie il faut pas s'isoler
merci beaucoup nicole bricq d'avoir
participé à l'autre émission et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine bonne
semaine à tous et à très bientôt sur les
chaînes parlementaires